well I want to begin with you when I saw
this film among the many things that I
was struck by is the unbelievable
contrast between the innocence of the
first hour and the brutality of the
second hour how would you describe the
journey that you were wanting to take
audiences on with this film why I
imagined a Norman Rockwell painting and
then plucking the characters from it and
dropping them into a hunter animus Bosch
and in a way that's that's kind of true
the first half is quite different from
the second and I think what must have
happened to men who go to war who you
know I don't think you know what to
expect from something like that and it's
kind of the death of their innocence and
it's a shock and so those two things
that and Robert will probably tell you
when he'll talk more about a structure
of a screenplay but it really it was
pretty obvious on the page what needed
to happen so well let me segue right to
Robert then what what was important to
you in contrasting those two halves well
it's a it's a it's oddly it's a two-act
structure it's not a standard three act
and this is totally driven by the story
and by the material and I think what we
all wanted to achieve with the startling
difference was to give the audience the
visceral experience that the Desmond das
and his companions and the Liberty
brigade were themselves experiencing so
you kind of set this thing up it's not
it you know it's not entirely bucolic
there's the darkness of his father his
father's violence the virus of that his
war experience and we see a play out in
the family but but this sense of place
and time and family and all the things
that were important to Desmond that made
him who he was and then rocket that into
the horror of the made us garment it was
a very conscious attendant bill from a
production point of view did you all
talk about shooting
the one-act all at the same time and
then at that point starting on the
second act were you able to do that did
you have to intersperse at times know
whether there was a before and after so
no the production schedule we had I
think a total of we had 42 days first
unit and 19 days I think it was
something like that for second unit so
it's made like an independent film so we
never had enough money to really do it
properly and nobody seemed to care so
you know you make do so the battle stuff
was all sorta was all in you know was
all continuous but the Lynchburg
Virginia stuff was before and after my
understanding is that one or more early
potential partners of yours on this film
were asking for it to be pg-13 yeah for
I mean this is this is 15 years so you
know a lot of it was being in again and
they let us out so that you know more
power to him I'm not angry about about
it but we finally got to I took regional
budget was done in 2002 there was about
the same level budget of brave arc was
that we did 23 years ago and we're about
half of that now and so he got the
budget down Mel had I'd actually offered
always thought Mel was the right
director it offered Mel the picture
twice that where he didn't say yes and
so I had I had another director who we
were ready to make it at one point and
we sat down with the financier and they
said it has to be a pg-13 and oh yeah it
has to be a soft pg-13 movie
and I went I don't know how to make that
movie you're taking the war out of the
picture and if you don't put Desmond
Dawson he'll it doesn't have the same
effect so also what force it out what
flipped the switch for you from being an
ode to a yes oh that's a interesting
question I think look you review things
you're ready there's a time place for it
I'm not quite sure what it was but it
worked its way into my system somehow
just profoundly moved when I read the
screenplay I was you know salty tears on
page 58 or something and I just I found
a way into it and I think I thought
about it a little bit and it just
resonated for me all of a sudden I'm a
bit thick it takes me a little while
Andrew your performance is so
spectacular
it's the and what's so fascinating about
Desmond das is that this guy's demeanor
is just unwavering you know in his whole
life and also just for a moment to
moment it's almost like Forrest Gump in
a way and you know that just completely
unshakable in his foundation how did you
arrive at how you were going to bring
that demeanor across yeah you know it's
a mystery it's all a mystery to me um
and he and Desmond is a mystery I think
that's one of the beauties of him how he
was able to do what he did and be who he
was amidst everyone telling him to be
something else it's a it's the most
common struggle we all have in the
current culture we're in right now how
do we hold on to our integrity in our
core amidst a society telling us to be
something opposite how do you be the
salmon swimming upstream this is the
work of our lives and I'm just
incredibly grateful that we got to tell
this story now and that I could be a
part of it I'm glad that it took 15
years so I'm also terribly sorry of
course but but selfishly and I think the
moment we're in maybe the world wasn't
wasn't as hungry for this story of
Desmond 15 years ago and I think you
have to get to where Andrew got to if
Mel Gibson and Andrew Garfield aren't in
this movie it's not the movie so I did
15 years as painful
but it's absolutely the right thing no
Vince in some ways you're totally
against type in some ways it's playing
right into your wheelhouse how did you
envision this this part when you first
read it and how exciting was it the idea
of taking it on well I had never heard
of the story so first I was just really
moved by the story that I had to look it
up afterwards I thought this might feel
a little bit stretched to her but that I
saw the documentary and it was just
really blown away by what this guy did
and then for the character which I
thought was great you know I have a lot
of military my family and I've gone with
the USO quite a bit to both Iraq and
Afghanistan so I know a lot of service
people and it was unique in this war
because the sergeant was training the
guys that he would take over there so
you really just start from a foundation
that you love these kids and you want to
stay alive and you take it to be your
responsibility
so whatever skills you have to reach
them so sense of humor sometimes can
work if you don't want to drown them out
entirely but you do have to shock them
and hopefully get them prepared so that
they can go back to their training in
the worst case of scenarios where
they're trying to stay alive then you
know Andrew did such a beautiful job in
those scenes with him with the shirt and
the dignity and the humanity and the
strength that he had in those settings
it was very easy to be present with that
and see the human being underneath it
and feel terrible about the circumstance
and yet at the same time still believe
your training that this was a bad fit
for him as well as the other guys so you
just sort of go through it Kevin I
really do feel like so much of the
visceral shock and horror of the
extended war scenes is credit to you and
so I'd be curious to know what what were
your approaches and what was most
important for you to get across well
thank you for that but but the reality
is is I was just one member of a very
talented team of sound people that put
together what you heard here tonight the
guys down in Australia of Rob McKenzie
and Andy Wright did a
amazing job of stepping up to the plate
and helping create what you saw here
tonight we took our lead from the actors
the actors were performing at at 10:00
and we said we need to step up to the
plate and honor what these guys are
doing here and also the way that mel
shot it you know it for those of you
know about the battle it was one of the
bloodiest battles if not the bloodiest
battle in the pacific and and you know
the way it's shot the way it's acted the
way it's you know the way the camera
works that the dialogue we had to step
up to the plate and equal that and sound
and we did our best to try to do that
and if we did then you felt like you
were out there on that battlefield with
those guys yeah Andrew what's the trick
to bringing across the idea of the
American South and the accent while
you're shooting in Sydney yeah and being
an English person right yeah
god what a wonderful thing to be able to
attempt and it's it kind of employs my
left brain which I don't often get to
use usually we were talking about
mystery earlier and how the and the
process of absorbing Desmond's essence
and attempting to ingest him and and
then emanate him somehow that's a
totally mysterious process and I can
only say attempted to do that I don't
know if I achieved it but I pray that I
wherever he is he feels he feels okay
about it that's all I can hope is his
son with his son saw the sort of film
and that was a very moving thing for all
of us to know that he his son was deeply
moved by he said his son said to me I've
always loved my dad but because of
seeing how this story's played out
because of what you guys have created
now I respect him he would never have
used that word before for his father
because he was always just daddy so that
was I think we gave him a gift which is
a you know what more can we hope for for
this kind of storytelling to transcend
merely you know making a film so that's
beautiful so the left brain I get to use
the left brain I get to use my vocal
muscles in a different way and it's like
something tangible that I feel I can
hold on to
and it in the midst of so much chaos and
mystery and terror about what what the
hell the next step is or what the hell
the next moment will be or what the hell
I'm doing in any moment at all there was
that vocal work for me is something that
I really just enjoy working like a
muscle it's almost like one of those
stress balls I kind of that's why I stay
in the accent all the time to not
confuse myself mostly and to not confuse
the other actors and because I think
that could be jarring I imagine it would
be for me so anyway yeah it's a
wonderful part of the prose I have a
great dialect coach called Liz
Himmelstein though I work with as well
who's absolutely wonderful so we we
compile music we compile different
voices and we basically try and create a
sound and it's just a lovely part of the
the process well I started with you and
I'll end with you as well because we
haven't touched on the concept of faith
tonight and I think that is such an
important part of this film and I'd be
curious to know where where did that
rank as far as the most important things
that you wanted to bring across as you
were putting it together I think the
film is it's about this man and very
intrinsic to who Desmond was was his
faith I mean this man's face was so
strong and it inspired me actually I
mean I like to think I've got a modicum
of faith but I do not believe I could do
what that man did to crawl into the jaws
of Hell with no weapon and lay his life
on the line over and over again for his
brothers I mean greater love hath no man
so you know I you know it's a it's an
undeniable and a necessary component in
this story and it you know you know the
an experience that reduces most men to
the level of animals this man goes in
and keeps his equilibrium and his
convictions and his faith intact and
it's maybe it's a little shaken around
and you know slapped around but he he
manages to sort of grit it out and do it
this is for me the main inspiration
thank you so much everybody
have a great night